sparen und an seiner seite der präsident
des paul ehrlich instituts professor dr
klaus cichutek und der leiter der
forschungsgruppe für infektions
immunologie und impfstoffforschung an
der charité herr professor leif erik
sande sie sind zu uns gekommen natürlich
mit blick auf die aktuellen berichte und
diskussionen über das impfen mit den
links stoffen moderner und bayern
bundesgesundheitsminister beginnt dann
had to black und dem herr professor
sammler bitte
lieber herr de thier meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren vielen dank
für die möglichkeit angesichts der
aktuellen entwicklungen noch einmal die
hintergründe unserer aktuellen
entscheidungen darzustellen
was etwas unterzugehen droht in mancher
berichterstattung das ist mir vorneweg
sehr wichtig moderner ist ein guter
sicherer und sehr wirksamer impfstoff
manche impfenden ärzte sagen biontech
ist der mercedes unter den impfstoffen
und moderner ist der rolls royce und ich
denke das macht sehr deutlich dass wir
eben zwei sehr gute impfstoffe mehr in
impfstoffe jetzt zur verfügung haben
sowohl für die erst die zweite impfung
wie auch für die auffrischimpfungen und
ich bin sehr dankbar dass der professor
hat sich weg und herr professor sander
das gleiche auch noch einmal
verdeutlichen werden die deutschen
werden momentan am häufigsten den
impfstoff von biontech und das ist ja
auch in ordnung so die nachfrage nach
dem impfstoff von beyond ist allerdings
in den letzten zwei wochen sehr sehr
stark gestiegen
allein in dieser woche heute vor allem
heute und morgen gehen sechs millionen
dosen des impfstoffes von beyond eck aus
unseren lagern in die versorgung in
deutschland
das ist mehr als es bisher überhaupt
insgesamt an auffrischimpfung in
deutschland gegeben hat und das muss
jetzt auch erst einmal verimpft werden
in der letzten woche sind gut zwei
millionen impfungen in deutschland
erfolgt das heißt also wenn wir jetzt
sechs millionen heute ausliefern ist das
auch in relation zu den letzten tagen
und wochen eine große menge und insofern
baut sich wahrscheinlich an vielen
stellen im land über die ganze
versorgungsstufe arztpraxis apotheke
großhandel auch ein gewisser ufer auf
alles in allem ist das erst mal eine
gute nachricht die ins kampagne läuft
wieder und weiter hoch und viele haben
sich offenbar und auch das ist ja gut
anders als in den wochen zuvor jetzt
dazu entschieden eine booster eine
auffrischimpfung zu machen oder auch
anzubieten
leider ist der eindruck entstanden wir
würden nur deshalb stärker auf den stoff
von moderner setzen um einen möglichen
verfall dieser impfstoffe im ersten
quartal 22 zu vermeiden das ist zwar ein
wichtiger aspekt das will ich
ausdrücklich sagen natürlich auch ein
aspekt aber es ist nicht der
entscheidende
entscheidend ist dass sich unser
biontech lager so schnell leert dass wir
ab der nächsten woche vorübergehend
nicht mehr als zwei bis drei millionen
dosen des impfstoffs pro woche
zur verfügung stellen können für die
versorgung und
das liefern wir dann auch aus alles was
wir haben und alles was wir neu
geliefert bekommen wird natürlich
ausgeliefert wir halten nichts zurück
ich gelegentlich lars am wochenende
insgesamt stehen so bis jahresende und
auch das ist wichtig insgesamt stehen so
bis jahresende
24 millionen dosen des biontech
impfstoff zur verfügung
wenn wir also damit planen davon
ausgehen dass wir 25 bis 30 millionen
auffrischimpfungen bis zum jahresende
machen wollen dann wird ein großer teil
dieser impfung wenn gewünscht auch mit
biontech stattfinden können und dazu
kommt noch moderner von moderner haben
wir 16 millionen booster dosen auf
fristlosen sofort in unseren lagern
verfügbar bis jahresende bis zu 26
millionen wir haben also von den beiden
m rna impfstoffen für erst zweit und
dritt impfung bis zu 50 millionen
impfdosen zur verfügung bis zum
jahresende das ist genug für alle
anstehenden
impfung
mir ist sehr bewusst dass diese
kurzfristige umstellung für viele
engagierte helferinnen und helfer vor
ort in den arztpraxen und den
impfzentren viel zusätzlichen aufwand
und auch stress bedeutet
geplante prozesse und abläufe müssen
umgestellt werden und sie müssen
überzeugungsarbeit leisten das weiß ich
und das bedaure ich auch
wichtig ist es ist genug impfstoff für
alle anstehenden impfungen da und beide
impfstoffe wirken wer die chance hat
sich
und andere mit einem der beiden
impfstoffe zu schützen der sollte ist
auch tun
danke herr minister und natürlich denke
ja vielen herzlichen dank ich habe hier
und bei vieler gelegenheit ausgedrückt
dass die zugelassenen kurve die
impfstoffe die wir in deutschland
verfügbaren hoch wirksam und sicher sind
an das anlass der derzeitigen diskussion
möchte ich noch mal deutlich darauf
hinweisen dass gerade die beiden erna
impfstoffe und zwar zwei klicks von
moderner aber auch kommunale von
bankhäusern sich durch besonders hohe
wirksamkeit auszeichnen und durch ein
besonders niedriges
risikoprofil
wie sind äquivalent und das haben wir
anlässlich der derzeitigen diskussion
insbesondere auf unserer webpage jetzt
noch mal deutlich dargestellt mit so
hofft die sicherheit in bezug auf die
sehr seltene nebenwirkungen die unter
zehn fällen pro 100000 kriegen sind
beide äquivalent die wirksamkeit und
effektivität in klinischen prüfung hat
sich als 90 prozent und höher
herausgestellt für beide impfstoffe die
dauer der des schutzes gegen kuwait und
insbesondere gegen schwere verläufe auch
in gegenwart der dominieren delta
variante beträgt fünf bis sechs monate
und entsprechende priorisierung bei der
booster impfung sind inzwischen
getroffen worden und auch in bezug auf
die plattform und die immunologie die
hinter den impfstoffen steht sind diese
impfstoffe durchaus sexual and und
deswegen für die hydrologie booster
impfung genauso wie die rummel logo
booster impfung sehr geeignet und sie
ergeben dass zeigen publizierte studien
hohe
antikörpertiter erhöhung nach der
booster impfung vielleicht auch noch mal
bei diesem anlass darauf hinweisen dass
beide impfstoffe zugelassen sind für die
auffrischimpfungen und zwar fällt es
sich so wie sie sicher wissen dass hier
bei der biontech booster impfung
dieselbe dosen verwendet werden soll wie
bei der grundimmunisierung die halbe
dosis bei spex moderne angesagt die
entsprechende präsentation ist da so
dass das kein problem ist im rahmen der
gmk beschlüsse aber auch in bezug auf
die stiko empfehlungen möchte ich noch
mal deutlich machen dass die auch
frische impfung mit spikes für personen
ab 30 jahren empfohlen werden kann das
entspricht auf der stiko empfehlung und
für alle schwangeren ab dem zweiten
trimenon für person von 18 bis 29 jahren
solle nach stiko empfehlung kumulativ
verwendet werden hier wird einfach
berücksichtigt dass es register studien
zur sicherheit der impfstoffe aus
nordischen ländern geht die
kreativität die wir sagen das heißt die
vorübergehenden impfreaktionen im rahmen
der ersten beiden es fünf tage zwischen
spitze und kunden durchaus äquivalent
mit einer tendenz zu etwas deutlicheren
impfreaktionen bei der zweiten und
sicher auch bei der dritten inc wo wir
haben auch in unserem letzten
sicherheitsbericht zum ende september
noch mal klar dargestellt dass wir auch
zu auffrischimpfung schon eine
auswertung bieten können und wir können
sagen dass die
schwerwiegenden melde raten meldeten
schwerwiegender reaktionen bei beiden
impfstoffen bei 0,1 2000
auffrischimpfung liegen und darunter das
sind sehr gute werte ganz am ende haben
viele viele studien inzwischen gezeigt
aus israel usa
kanada und her sondern geht vielleicht
auch das eingefahren deutschland
begleitet sein will dass die büste rung
kannst ausgezeichnet ist das heißt ja
haben sehr hohe stärkung der
antikörpertiter und da beide impfstoffe
auch die zelluläre immunantwort
ansprechenden gehe ich davon aus dass es
auch die erhöht werden kann
zusammenfassend kann man sagen beide
impfstoffe sind äquivalent können
homologen tetro lob für die booster
impfung verwendet werden da gibt es
keine zweifel in bezug auf die datenlage
mit so hofft die zu lassen und in bezug
auf die studien die nach der zulassung
inzwischen untersucht und ergebnisse
gebracht habe vielen dank dank airbag
und herr professor sander
vielen dank vorweg zu sagen bevor wir
nochmal über die details der booster
impfung sprechen vielleicht noch mal
vorweg einfach finde ich es wichtig noch
mal zu sagen dass die die steil
ansteigenden inzidenz und die sich
zuspitzende lage muss man ja sagen in
den krankenhäusern intensivstationen in
erster linie
einer nebel zu niedrige impfquote
geschuldet sind wir haben ja in
deutschland das große glück und das
haben wir gerade gehört freien zugang zu
den besten sichersten und modernsten
impfstoffen gegen 9.10 zu haben und wir
müssen dieses geschenk unbedingt
annehmen es besteht aus meiner sicht
überhaupt keinen zweifel dass wir heute
in einer komplett anderen situation
wären wenn sich alle erwachsenen in
deutschland dagegen hätten es vollkommen
klar wir bekommen normalität nur durch
immunität und das funktioniert
nachhaltig eben nur über eine
flächendeckende impfung und deswegen
müssen wir alles unternehmen um die
impflücken zu schließen wir wissen aber
auch das haben wir im verlauf des jahres
festgestellt dass der impfschutz nach
zwei impfungen mit der zeit etwas
nachlässt und
insbesondere auch der schutz vor
infektionen und weitergabe des virus mit
der zeit ab gerade wegen der hoch
ansteckenden delta variante und sich
deswegen zunehmend auch geimpfte wieder
am infektionsgeschehen beteiligen können
bei älteren vor erkrankten personen
sieht man in israelischen daten
zunehmend leider auch in deutschland
kann zudem der schutz vor schwerer
erkrankungen leicht nachlassen wobei zu
betonen gilt das ist immer noch deutlich
ist deutlich besser und deutlich über
dem niveau von ungeimpften personen
insgesamt sprechen aber alle daten klar
dafür dass es letzten endes auf 1 3
dieses schema hinauf hinauslaufen wird
das würde ich habe beim letzten mal an
dieser stelle ja schon ziemlich viel
über die vorzüge der booster impfung
gesprochen und herzig und ersparen haben
das ja auch schon getan aber vielleicht
noch mal um das zu verdeutlichen die
daten aus israel legen nahe dass mit
einer booster impfung der schutz oder
das dass das risiko einer erkrankung
noch mal um das 10 bis 20 fache
gegenüber zweitgrößten reduziert werden
kann und jetzt gibt es auch daten aus
placebokontrollierten studien die
ebenfalls die effektivität einer booster
impfung mit 95 prozent gegenüber der
regulären zweifach-impfung angeben und
das sind alles effekte die sehr
beeindruckend sind und den
herausragenden nutzen der dritten
impfung noch einmal darlegen im logisch
ist es auch nicht überraschend
wir kennen das ja von anderen
impfstoffen und mit der zweiten nach der
zweiten impfung bekommt das immunsystem
sozusagen ein wenig zeit um nach zu
schärfen und mit der dritten impfung
werden dann spezifisch diese
ausgereiften gedächtniszellen noch mal
aktiviert und der der impfschutz kann
dadurch nochmal deutlich verbessert
werden und diese effekte müssen wir
jetzt konsequent nutzen daher die breite
buser kampagne wie sie jetzt ja auch
angelaufen ist und glücklicherweise ja
auch genug impfstoff zur verfügung steht
müssen wir jetzt beschleunigen generell
wird empfohlen und herzig als auch
gerade schon gesagt dass die dritte
impfung mit einem m rna impfstoff
durchgeführt wird und das ist unabhängig
davon welchen impfstoff sie für die
grundimmunisierung verwendet haben sie
können einen mm stoff verwenden die
kombination unterschiedlicher impfstoffe
ja sogar unterschiedlicher impfstoff
typen ist problemlos möglich das konnten
wir im frühjahr unter anderem bier und
viele andere in studien zeigen dass die
sogenannte kreuz impfung sogar
immunologische vorteile bieten kann und
mittlerweile ist die studienlage
dazu auch sehr sehr solide
für die booster impfung liegen wir uns
aktuell zwar die größten datensätze für
den biotech impfstoff vor jedoch gibt es
auch sehr sehr gute daten für den
impfstoff von moderner beide impfstoffe
und erzählt eckert gesagt sind von der
bauart im prinzip identisch
die bisherigen studien könnten sogar
nahe legen dass moderner geimpfte einen
leichten vorteil laden könnten gegenüber
montag dürften meiner meinung nach ist
das quasi ein akademischer unterschied
den man sich angucken das marginale
unterschiede auf hohem niveau die beiden
impfstoffe wirken beide sehr sehr gut
und
[Musik]
fest steht einfach dass wir mit diesen
zwei impfstoffen zwei hoch effektive und
videothek auch gerade noch mal
ausgeführt hat extrem sichere impfstoffe
zur verfügung haben
somit ist aus meiner sicht mit hinblick
auf die wirksamkeit die wahl des mr
neuem stoff für die booster impfung
eigentlich egal ja da sind sich auch die
führenden in monologen hierzulande einig
wir haben uns auch noch mal in den
letzten tagen besprochen dessen beides
hervorragende impfstoffe die für die
booster impfung gleich gut funktionieren
und
wie er zeigt auf sagte wissen sie dass
für personen unter 30 jahren aktuell
prioritär der biontech impfstoff
eingesetzt werden soll und daher ist es
aus meiner sicht auch vollkommen logisch
dass zb impfungen bei älteren je nach
verfügbarkeit auch primär mit moderner
durchgeführt werden können wichtig ist
an dieser stelle nochmal zu sagen dass
moderner für die booster impfung in der
halben dosierung also 50 mikrogramm
eingesetzt wird walter und das ist auch
so der letzten stiko empfehlung zu
entnehmen kurzgefasst beide impfstoffe
funktionieren sowohl in der
grundimmunisierung als auch in der
booster impfung ganz hervorragend man
kann im grunde genommen sagen sie können
beruhigt das nehmen was gerade da ist
beide impfstoffe werden sie sehr sehr
gut schützen und beide sind sehr gut
verträglich und die stiko sieht das
übrigens in ihrer letzten stellungnahme
ganz genauso und im grunde fragt man bei
der grippeschutzimpfung ja auch nicht
nachdem herr teller sondern man möchte
gute impfung bekommen und die bekommt
man mit egal welcher dieser zwei
hersteller und auch als arzt möchte ich
das betonen dass wir mit beiden
impfstoffen sehr gute erfahrungen haben
und wir natürlich durch die bank sehr
sehr gute auch immunantworten gegen
beide impfstoffe sehen am ende bleibt
also noch mal festzuhalten
wir haben die besten stoffe in
ausreichender menge wir haben ein hoch
ansteckendes virus das sich bei
niedriger impfquote wie wir jetzt leider
sehen relativ ungehindert verbreiten
können und unser gesundheitssystem an
die grenzen des leistbaren treiben wird
nur die impfung kann uns da rausholen
und deshalb müssen sich alle impfen
lassen vielen dank
danke herr plesser so jetzt haben wir
viele fragen fangen sie themen aus dem
saarland hessen dann der winkel
ja ich habe eine frage an herrn sander
wie lange hält nach derzeitigem stand
ein weitgehend der impfschutz durch die
booster impfung vor wir hatten in der
vergangenen woche auch herrn professor
wieder danach gefragt weil es bei denen
die im zögerlich sind die vermutung gibt
man müsse sich dann alle sechs monate
sozusagen im abonnement impfen lassen
will sagte es gebe ihm seien keine daten
bekannt wie lange der impfschutz nach
der dritten dann anhält war ihnen krank
ist jetzt so als werde dadurch mit
einiger sicherheit dauerhaft ein schutz
aufgebaut wie ist es jetzt tatsächlich
also das kann die natürlich mit
abschließender sicherheit noch noch
niemand sagen einfach weil die booster
impfung gerade angelaufen sind
es ist so dass es zum dass wir das aus
erfahrung mit anderen impfstoffen wirken
dass gerade zum zeitversetzte dritte
dosis daneben das immun gedächtnis
nochmal stärkt und sie dann eine
immunantwort bekommen die einfach lang
andauern da ist wir sehen das auch in
unseren eigenen untersuchungen ich habe
hier auch sogar die daten mitgebracht
selbst bei älteren menschen steigt kann
ihn auch gerne mal zeigen steigt im
prinzip nach sechs monaten sind die hier
unten und nach der dritten sind vom
steigen die so hoch wie sie vorher noch
nie waren und selbst wenn die antikörper
mit derselben geschwindigkeit wieder
abfallen würden wie nach der zweiten
impfung hätten wir damit deutlich mehr
zeit aus meiner perspektive
als wir das nach der zweiten impfung
haben ich gehe im grunde davon aus dass
findet lang anhalterin lang anhaltenden
schutz bekommen werden ich habe studien
gesehen zu den chinesischen impfstoffen
die nach der zweite in form sehr rasch
ihre wirkung verlieren und nach der
dritten von zumindest über 100 tage also
die daumen drei monate komplett stabil
geblieben sind daraus kann man das jetzt
nicht zwangsweise schließen dass wir mit
der 3 mit dem 3 dieses schema komplett
durch sind wir wissen auch nicht was für
tricks letzten endes das virus noch
drauf hat ob wir da irgendwann nochmal
nachschärfen müssen aber ich würde
denken dass wir jetzt erstmal mit der
dritten impfung die immunisierung
abgeschlossen haben das wäre meine
hoffnung aber im prinzip kann es
natürlich sein dass wir gelegentlich da
noch mal nachbessern müssen linke
hätte frage an herrn spahn sie haben
jetzt beschrieben dass genügend
impfstoff da ist aber es gibt ja den
wunsch nach piontek haben sie mit dem
unternehmen gesprochen über mögliche
nachlieferung es gibt ja schon berichtet
das war ja und zehn millionen dosen
glaube ich zugesagt habe und haben sie
mit dem unternehmen auch gesprochen
wandern jetzt der kinder im stoff kommt
also wirklich erst an weihnachten oder
schon ein bisschen früher
also zuerst einmal sind wir wurden in
beständigen austausch natürlich mit
allen impfstoffherstellern insbesondere
auch mit biontech
und ja natürlich bemühen wir uns die
menge der verfügbaren dosen auch ab
nächster woche ich sage noch einmal weil
ich heute auch von ärzten die ich aus
der heimat kennen die sorge da war
kriegen wir heute unsere lieferung diese
woche wird alles ausgeliefert wie
bestellt 6 millionen dosen biontech
gehen heute zur minute sozusagen in die
versorgung in deutschland aber natürlich
wollen wir auch in den folgewochen wenn
es eben geht
das angebot weiter erhöhen dass man
zwischen zwei guten impfstoffen wählen
kann dessen bin ich auch persönlich aber
ja auch unser ministerium im gespräch
mit dem unternehmen
ich halte aber nichts davon über zahlen
zu spekulieren das bringt jetzt noch
mehr durcheinander wenn die dinge klar
sind wann was dann werden wir es auch
kommunizieren eine botschaft bleibt aber
weiterhin wichtig auch der impfstoff von
moderner
kann soll und muss mit in die versuchung
die herausforderung besteht der jetzt
gerade darin und das ist eben auch das
weil einige der fragen konntet ihr das
nicht alles vielleicht schon vor zwei
wochen so sehen wir haben eigentlich
seit ich weiß nicht wir waren ja auch
schon öfter in pressekonferenzen seit
sommer für auffrischimpfung geworden
hatten aber eine relativ verhaltene
nachfrage über einen langen zeitraum
und dann so für ein zwei wochen hoch ist
ab und wir haben letzte woche noch eine
reihe von nachbestellungen und zusatz
lieferungen möglich gemacht weil wir
natürlich wollen dass schnellstmöglich
alles raus gehen wir haben doch noch mal
möglich gemacht dass die arztpraxen
nachbestellen können er ist letzte woche
entgegen dem üblichen rhythmus was auch
richtig war aber das alles führt dazu
dass eben diese woche unerwartet viel
auf einmal abfließt das wollte ich auch
möglich machen
und das führt aber eben dazu dass wir
zumindest in den folgewochen ich sage
noch einmal zwei bis drei millionen
dosen ist ja nicht nichts jede woche an
biontech und darüber hinaus alles was
ein moderner bestellt wird werden
ausliefern können und wenn es gelingt
mit dem unternehmen bestimmte
lieferungen sozusagen vorzuziehen
zusätzlich möglich zu machen wenn wir
das natürlich auch tun aber ich möchte
das halt erst konkret machen wenn es
konkret ist weil sonst glaube ich bringt
es eher noch mehr durcheinander was die
frage des kinder impfstoffs angeht ist
auch das wichtig die ganze europäische
union bekommt die lieferung am 20 12 -
die zulassung wird wahrscheinlich
herzlich ende dieser woche erfolgen
und dann wird eben die lieferung in der
zweiten dezemberhälfte sein das hat
damit zu tun dass das tatsächlich eine
unterschiedliche dosierung ist eine
andere abfüllung dass die chargen
freigaben auch erfolgen müssen und
anderes mehr das hat also einen anderen
vorlauf als schon das eingespielte
system der bereits im markt befindlichen
impfstoffe und dann werden wir auf einen
schlag 2,4 millionen dosen bekommen dass
kinder impfstoffs 5 bis 11 jährige wir
haben etwa viereinhalb millionen kinder
in dem alter in deutschland ich denke
mit 2,4 millionen dosen werden einen
großen teil der nachfrage dann auch
tatsächlich schon bedienen können und
natürlich gibt es dann in 20 22 anfang
des jahres auch weitere lieferungen
so dann machen wir im saal weiter grimm
und dann die kollegin rechts
jetzt haben es ja ersparen ich wollte
sie noch mal ihre position weil die
debatte jetzt an tempo gewinnt
impfpflicht erfragen im pflichtbereich
lange zeit und deutschland seitens der
politiker als ausgeschlossen jetzt
bewegt sich da einiges wollte noch mal
nach ihrer einschätzung danach fragen
und auch einen der beiden professoren
ob eine impfpflicht aus geologischer
sicht angezeigt ist oder ob es auch ohne
geht
also zuerst einmal sie kennen meine
skeptische haltung was verpflichtende
impfung in dieser pandemie angeht und er
hat sich auch nichts geändert
gleichzeitig sehe ich meine aufgabe als
geschäftsführender minister immer gang
dass wenn die neue ich finde mehrheit
und bittet ein gesetzentwurf zu
erarbeiten der jetzt das umsetzt was am
donnerstag vereinbart wurde eine
verpflichtende impfung in bestimmten
berufsgruppen dass wir natürlich diesen
gesetzentwurf für diese
elementare mehrheit erarbeiten meine
grundsätzliche haltung hat sich dadurch
aber nicht verändert was zum zweiten
jahr bleibt ist ein umstand den wir
schon seit monaten beschreiben
wahrscheinlich wird am ende dieses
winters
so ziemlich jeder in deutschland
wie das feld wurde er manchmal schon
etwas zynisch genannt geimpft chinesen
oder gestorben sein
aber es ist tatsächlich so mit der sehr
ansteckenden delta variante ist das sehr
sehr
wahrscheinlich und deswegen empfehlen
wir ja so dringlich die impfung auch die
erste impfung weiterhin dass wir nicht
geimpft ist sich ohne schutz infizieren
wird in den nächsten monaten eher sei
denn man passt wirklich sehr sehr sehr
sehr gut in jeder lebenslage auf und
insofern immunität wird immer erreicht
die frage ist ob durch impfung oder
durch infektionen und wir empfehlen
ausdrücklich den weg über die impfung
die frage ob dann tatsächlich eine
weitergehende verpflichtende impfung
angezeigt ist oder nicht finde ich
musste man auch noch nicht jetzt und
heute beantworten die hilft nämlich für
die nächsten vier wochen so oder so
nicht wir haben gerade eine tabelle eine
sehr sehr schwierige lage in vielen
kliniken in deutschland vor allem im
moment im südosten des landes aber wir
sehen ja gerade diese welle sich
sozusagen
schritt für schritt weiter nach westen
entwickeln und auch entwickeln wird auch
durch europa durchgehend wir sehen dass
selbst länder mit dänemark und
frankreich die sehr hohe im noch höhere
impfquoten damals deutschland auch
gerade beginnen in eine wieder
schwierigere situation zu kommen das
alles muss doch jetzt zuerst unser fokus
sein also wir können über alles
diskutieren aber ich finde es erstmal
gut wenn wir über das diskutieren was
jetzt ansteht und was jetzt ansteht ist
vor allem diese welle zu brechen und
keine verpflichtende impfung
bricht jetzt diese welle sondern diese
welle wird gebrochen durch kontakt
reduzierung durch entschiedenes
staatliches handeln auf basis auch
dessen was
donnerstag und freitag beschlossen wurde
zwischen bund und ländern und in den
parlamenten und
zusätzlich eben auch durch viele viele
auffrischimpfungen aber selbst die
können nicht innerhalb von zwei wochen
den entscheidenden unterschied machen
deswegen können wir alle debatten mit
der nötigen ruhe dann auch führen die
geführt werden sollen und geführt werden
wollen ich empfehle uns aber jetzt mal
uns darauf zu konzentrieren und erstmal
das zu regeln was auch wirklich
dringlich ansteht
die kollegen
vor ihnen ist das mikrofon an
achso entschuldigung gegeben hatte in
der tat natürlich hat der gesamte
angesprochen es ist eindeutig so dass im
moment angesagt ist dass sich die
personen ostern lassen die das können
wir haben dazu ganz klare empfehlungen
es müssen die grundimmunisierung
abgeschlossen werden wenn das noch nicht
passiert auf ihre logische sieht es
unbedingt wichtig dass sich personen die
gefährdet sind insbesondere schützen
oder postern lassen das wort die
verantwortung übernehmen die in kontakt
sind mit personen die besonderer
gefährdung unterliegen und die insofern
auch diese personen sich impfen lassen
dass es aus wie rollo gitter und dem
logischer sicht angesagt
vielleicht kann ich noch ergänzen das
was diskutiert wird eine einrichtung
bezogene impfpflicht also letzten endes
in einrichtungen wie hochschulen haben
patienten oder menschen versorgt werden
das betrifft dann ehrlich noch eine
bestimmte berufsgruppe sagte ich alle
menschen die in dieser einrichtung
arbeiten finde ich haben eben eine
verpflichtung gegenüber den personen die
dort die sie dort betreuen sich
bestmöglich zu schützen und auch diese
personen zu schützen das geht meines
erachtens daneben auch über maßnahmen
die voraussetzen dass alle die in so
einer einrichtung arbeiten geimpft sind
und ich glaube es gibt wirklich keinen
zwei meinung alle erwachsene zumindest
in deutschland müssen sich impfen lassen
die immunität über eine infektion ist
eigentlich keine alternative die man
hier diskutieren kann weil das eben zu
massiven belastungen gesundheitswesen
führt zu einer 567 welle führt und das
kann ja wirklich niemand wollen sie
können uns als nicht als arzt zudem
monologen nicht fragen wie man dieses
ziel erreicht dann müssen nicht andere
leute gedanken darüber machen aber es
ist für mich absolut alternativlos alle
müssen sich impfen und die kommunikation
sozusagen man man könne sich impfen das
sei man hätte eine andere alternative
ist im grunde haben nicht richtig
sondern alle müssen sich im grunde
impfen lassen das möchte ich einfach
noch mal unterstreichen welche
diskussion den letzten tagen auch wieder
erlebt habe da möchte manch ein einfach
mal auf die intensivstation zerren damit
sie sehen was dieses virus anrichtet und
gerade einmal mehr auch bedeutet für die
kliniken für die pflegekräfte für die
ärztin und ärzte für alle die dort
arbeiten aber auch das leid ist für die
patienten und ihre angehörigen bringt
auch das kommt ja noch dazu
man fragt sich wirklich was noch
passieren muss ist wirklich der letzte
versteht dass diese impfung einen selbst
zuerst einmal schützt aber eben vor
allem auch für uns alle als gesellschaft
dann auch sicherheit gibt insofern sehe
ich eine unbedingte moralische
verpflichtung sich impfen zu lassen und
ich habe die tage auch von führenden
politikern des deutschen bundestages
einmal mehr gehört das wäre keine frage
von solidarität ob man sich impfen lässt
oder nicht so eine persönliche frage ist
stimmt einfach nicht
die frage ob man sich impfen lässt oder
nicht betrifft immer auch andere schon
jenseits der pandemie aber in dieser
pandemie ganz besonders und das ist
gehört schon zu meinem verständnis von
freiheit
dass ich einfach verantwortung übernehme
mit dieser freiheit und mit dieser
freien entscheidung und deswegen damit
dass auch klipp und klar ist ja
aus meiner sicht gibt es eine
solidarische pflicht
sich impfen zu lassen
christine dankbar berliner zeitung eine
frage habe ich an herrn spahn oder zwei
und zwar in sachen vorhin das wäre
anfangs ja nur eine verhaltene reaktion
gewesen auf die aufforderung sich
bewusst an zulassen dass heute sehe ich
das richtig dass ich sozusagen selber
überrascht sind von ihr vom erfolg ihres
aufrufs und dass deswegen gibt es nicht
genug zwei hektar ist und die frage die
danach
daraus resultiert sie sagten diese woche
würde alles noch so ausgeliefert aber ab
nächster woche wird dann
rationiert sowie das kommuniziert wurde
oder wie sieht es dann aus mit den
lieferungen für die arztpraxen von
teilweise verärgert reagiert haben weil
sie sagen das tangiert ihre termine ich
schließe jetzt bei der gelegenheit
nochmal über wir sehr viele fragen von
außen haben da zwei an die das ergänzen
nämlich
sonja alvarez von der wirtschafts auch
gefragt ob sie das nicht hätten
vorhersehen können wenn sie zu impfungen
auf raich aus aufrufen einerseits und
zum boostern dass dann die biotech
nachfolge steigt also haben sie falsch
gestellt und rebecca beerheide vom
ärzteblatt fragt können sie den ärger
ärztinnen und ärzte die kolleginnen auch
karte wert haben verstehen
also zum ersten freut mich einfach
darüber dass das was wir ja schon seit
vielen wochen auch sagen dass das
notwendig ist nämlich eben das ist eine
auffrischimpfung gibt es das so stark
angezogen hat ich werde noch mal die es
in der abfolge beschreiben wir haben
anfang august miteinander vereinbart
bund und länder mit den erkenntnissen
die wir hatten dass es für ältere über
60 jährige menschen mit bestimmten
vorerkrankungen medizinisches
pflegerisches personal sehr viel sinn
macht eine dritte eine auffrischimpfung
zu bekommen vor allem auch um zu
schützen herr professor sander hat ja
gerade auch noch mal die enorme
verstärkung des schutzes grad in dieser
personengruppe
beschrieben
auch da hätte man sich im nachhinein
überall gewünscht dass das dann auch
direkt deutlich stärker anzieht in eine
pflegeeinrichtung geimpft wird manche
länder am sofort begonnen in den
pflegeeinrichtungen zu impfen man hier
haben vor drei vier wochen erst begonnen
aber das entscheidende ist dass es jetzt
passiert und dann kamen die erkenntnisse
unter anderem und insbesondere auch aus
israel aber auch aus anderen studien
dass eigentlich zwei erkenntnisse die
miteinander zusammenhängen nämlich dass
eben auch bei den jüngeren
vor allem der schutz durch die impfung
vor einer infektion und davor andere
anzustecken nachlässt als erstes
fünf sechs monaten je nach impfstoff
und das zum zweiten das eben mit der
delta variante dann eine solche welle
auch weiter befördern kann das also
geimpfte dadurch auch stärker wieder
teil desinfektions geschehens werden als
wir es vorher vermutet hatten
und mit dieser neuen erkenntnis haben
wir dann ja angepasst auch das war ja
ein prozess
sozusagen alle erst mal gemeinsam zu der
erkenntnis kommen mussten dass es viel
sinn macht vorsorglich vor allem auch um
eine vierte welle zu brechen oder
mitzuhelfen dass sie gebrochen wird alle
über 18 jährigen nach etwa sechs monaten
auf frisch zu impfen und auch da fing es
erst langsam mal an und jetzt hat es
sehr stark nachgezogen sowas wie möglich
gemacht haben in wahrheit ist ja mit der
nachbestellung auch in der letzten woche
ist das im moment mit der auslieferung
heute und den noch nicht verimpft
sonntag impfstoffen aus den letzten zwei
wochen es ist ja nicht so als ob alles
was wir aus beliefert hätten in den
letzten zwei wochen schon verimpft wäre
da sehen wir ja an den zahlen wie viele
impfungen wie viel wurde ausgeliefert
mit dem was leute aus liefern dürften
etwa acht bis neun millionen bei montech
dosen sozusagen in der versorgung seien
in den arztpraxen in den apotheken in
den impfzentren wo auch immer gerade
geimpft wird und wenn ich einfach schaue
auf die impfzahlen der letzten zwei drei
wochen ist das jetzt nicht innerhalb von
vier tagen weg das heißt also was sehr
gut ist es wird gerade in der versorgung
ein puffer aufgebaut
den kühlschränken in den apotheken in
den praxen in impfzentren und das ist
gut
aber dadurch dass dieser puffer jetzt so
stark in dieser woche aufgebaut wird und
dass das so zu sagen so gemacht wird
das haben wir so jedenfalls in dieser
dimension nicht vorhergesehen und das
hat eben dazu geführt als wir mittwoch
die zusammengeführten daten hatten sie
ausgewertet haben dass wir dann am
freitag zu der entsprechenden
entscheidung gekommen sind dass eben für
nächste woche so angehen zu müssen und
jetzt sage ich noch einmal zwei bis drei
millionen dosen in der nächsten woche
ist in relation zu dem was bis jetzt pro
woche verübt worden ist in den letzten
zwei wochen immer noch ziemlich viel an
beyond inc aber wir können nicht alle
bestellungen voll bedient die frage war
was übrigens übrigens wichtig ist
nochmal zu den bestellmengen moderner
wird unbegrenzt
ausgeliefert werden können je nachdem
wie viel bestellt wird davon haben wir
16 millionen booster dosen sozusagen auf
lager können auch direkt ausliefern bei
den entsprechenden bestellungen bei
biontech muss ich eben jetzt
vorübergehend ist zumindest mal in der
jeweiligen woche b grenzen verstehe ich
den ärger der ärztin und erste ja
natürlich verstehe ich den spürt ihn
auch
das ist auch okay
weil ich ja weiß das natürlich ich meine
das eine sind sieben
impfungen pro fläschchen pro weil das
andere sind 20 das ist ein anderer
ablauf in zeit und muss man die
patienten dann etwas anders einbestellen
die frage unter 30 über 30 spielt dann
noch mal anders eine eine rolle ich
verstehe dass
einer einem anderen aspekt übrigens hat
modernen vorteil man muss die rtl
lösungen nicht noch also es ist schon
konfektioniert zumindest den vorteil
gibt es bei der impfung an der stelle
ist etwas weniger arbeit aber ja ich
verstehe den ärger ich bedauere das auch
ausdrücklich
trotzdem ist es jetzt im miteinander
auch wichtig dass deutlich bleibt dass
wir zwei gute impfstoffe haben also dass
jetzt über diese debatte die wir gerade
führen nicht der eindruck entsteht der
falsche eindruck entsteht sondern dass
der eindruck bleibt wenn nämlich richtig
ist wir haben zwei sehr gute mm stoffel
zu versuchen zur impfung zur verfügung
auch zur auffrischimpfung und das ist
schon eine ziemlich
gute situation auch im vergleich zu
vielen anderen ländern auf der welt wir
haben ausreichend impfstoff und zwar gut
ich da mal eine frage von jens peter
paul
zu ihrer kommunikationsstrategie
er sagt warum haben sie und die haus
innerhalb eines wochenendes dreimal ihre
begründung der inform bayern tech
rationiert werden soll hinweis auf
verfallsdatum von moderner verpflichtung
zu spenden als ausland dann der erfolg
der booster kampagne
also die den zweite kommt nicht von uns
ich weiß jetzt nicht was das für eine
begründung ist von wem das habe ich ja
gerade gesagt es ist nicht deutlich
genug geworden dass natürlich die
verfalls frage schon auch ein thema ist
ich finde das thema wunder zumindest mal
aussprechen ob das eigentlich ethisch
verantwortbar ist wenn auf der ganzen
welt impfstoffmangel ist dass wir einen
der teuersten und besten impfstoffe
denen es gibt einfach sehenden auges
verfallen hat er zumindest eine debatte
die aus meiner sicht nur ein teilaspekt
der mit da rein gehört aber es ist eben
nicht entscheiden und das ist ja das was
ich gerade gesagt habe das hätten wir
klarer kommunizieren müssen das ist vor
allem auch darum geht dass wir nicht was
zurückhaltend man verstehe ich den ärger
besonders wenn man den eindruck hat die
hätten eigentlich mehr könnten nicht
erhalten nicht zurück sondern wir
liefern alles aus was die frage der der
spenden ins ausland an angeht ist das
von uns jedenfalls nicht
als begründung herangezogen wurden für
irgendwas ich werde nochmal die
größenordnung seien von 120 millionen
bisher ausgelieferten dosen biontech an
deutschland und von über 130 millionen
die deutschland insgesamt bekommt
biontech 130 millionen dosen dieses jahr
sind zehn millionen die wir mit dem rest
der welt geteilt haben ich finde das ist
alles in allem eine sehr verantwortbare
größenordnung und auch einfach unserer
verantwortung in der welt angemessen
vielleicht auch zu den gesamtzahlen bei
kovacs wir haben stand heute eben 68
millionen dosen der welt zur verfügung
gestellt 32 oder 31 gut 31 millionen von
astra zenica knapp 27 millionen von
johnson johnson und eben zehn millionen
von bayern tag sind schon mal 68
millionen weil wir eben auch ein
interesse daran haben ein eigenes
nationales interesse daran haben dass
auch der rest der welt wird mit dieser
pandemie unter kontrolle kommt
das wird jetzt als auch dazu fragen gibt
die hier schon rausgelegt habe die
deutschen tragen also nicht kuba wie das
sind die zahlen also was deutschland an
kovacs gegeben hat oder zugesagt hat das
ist jetzt in der umsetzung
68 millionen dosen bisher möglich war
denn da gab es die frage neben
aufschlüsselung der deutschen
zulieferung an kovacs
oder gefragt impfstoffdosen gehen in
diesem jahr noch an kovacs können sie da
sagen was da schon draußen ist und was
nicht dann also was draußen ist ich habs
gerade ich kann wenn ich einfach nochmal
asta zenica es ist zum teil in der
auslieferung noch nicht ausgeliefert
aber zugesagt ich sage jetzt mal was
fest zugesagt ist für dieses jahr ein
teil davon ausgeliefert 31,4 millionen
astra zenica
26,6 millionen johnson & johnson 10,3
millionen sonntag bereits in der
auslieferung das sind zusammen etwa 68
millionen dosen die deutschland an
kovacs gibt um andere länder auf der
welt zu unterstützen bei ihrer
impfkampagne was jetzt noch weiter folgt
werden jetzt natürlich im lichte der
bedarf für die wir selbst haben dann
entsprechend schlussfolgern gut jetzt
gehen wir hier im saal weiter und ich
weiß nicht welche fragen der kollege
dort hatte sich meldet dann hinterher
mit ihnen
ersparen sie hatten jetzt stehen die
enge der hausärzte mehrfach erwähnten
bedauert und auch nachvollziehen können
können sie auch nachvollziehen dass die
bürgerforen sicher sind dass
eine zurückhaltung von bayern tag einen
tag nachdem fuster aufruf für alle
rationiert werden soll und möchte mich
dafür entschuldigen für chaos für
versicherung für bedenken für
zusätzliche zweifel entstehen die frage
ist doch welche was die entscheidende
botschaft ist die entscheidende
botschaft ist liebe bürgerinnen und
bürger wir haben ausreichend impfstoff
für erst zweit und dritt impfungen in
deutschland 50 millionen dosen
das ist doch die entscheidende botschaft
und ich finde es jetzt sehr wichtig bei
allem verständlichen ärger und dem auch
was ich bedauere
dass wir doch die botschaft gemeinsam
auch senden und dafür bin ich auch sehr
dankbar dass wir das hier machen dass
wir zwei gute sichere sehr wirksame
impfstoffe zur verfügung haben und zwar
in ausreichender menge das ist doch der
entscheidende teil wenn wir das
gemeinsam kommunizieren ausreichend
impfstoff und während das hat gesagt was
da ist bitte nehmen weil gut eine
kurzfassung
dass das doch die entscheidende
botschaft ist und die es geht ich habe
im übrigen er am freitag aktiv von mir
ausgesagt dass werden moderner werden in
zukunft viel stärker mit einsetzen
müssen weil alleine mit beyond es dass
mit dem auffrischen nicht geht ich hab's
ja gesagt aber
offenkundig hätte ich noch etwas
ausführlicher dann hier auch darstellen
müssen damit dann nicht die falschen
eindruck entstehen kann vielleicht kann
man wirklich dazu noch mal beruhigen
weil ich habe das auch wahrgenommen am
wochenende weil ich mit unheimlich
vielen anfragen überhäuft wurde ob das
dann ging ja man hätte er vorher
biontech bekommen und eben glaube diese
botschaft ist eben wahrscheinlich in der
bevölkerung nicht so klar gewesen man
kann dann eben einen anderen impfstoff
nehmen für die auffrischung und das
funktioniert genauso gut und deswegen
glaube ich ist die verunsicherungen die
es da gibt unbegründet und da geht es
jetzt eben einfach zu informieren und
wichtig ist ja tatsächlich dass man eben
weiterhin die möglichkeit hat das machen
und ob man jetzt moderne oder biontech
bekommt ist im grunde genommen egal
vielleicht auch noch ergänzen aus
unserer sicht sie müssen bedenken wir
sitzen hier in deutschland im
schlaraffenland
aufgrund der vorausschauenden aktionen
der politik auch des
gesundheitsministers haben wir
ausreichend impfstoffe zur verfügung die
alle zugelassen sehr gut geprüft sind
und die sich auch im feld als effektiv
hoch wirksam und sicher erweisen in
dieser situation halte ich die
diskussion wirklich für unangemessen
darüber zu streiten warum die zwei
wirklich sehr guten rna impfstoffe jetzt
nicht ausgetauscht werden können das ist
eine unangemessene diskussion
hinsichtlich der lage wir haben wir
haben einen gemeinsamen feind dass die
pandemie und die das virus und ich kann
nur appellieren an alle sich jetzt
impfen zu lassen oder gegebenenfalls
boostern zu lassen das ist die messe der
saison das was zugelassen ist ist gut er
eine einem stoffe zeichnen sich aus
durch eine besonders hohe wirksamkeit
und einer äußerst niedrig wirkungsgrad
nehmen sie die und das ist genau das was
sie in diesem land zur verfügung haben
viele andere länder sehen sich danach
es gebe eine reihe weiter
vielen dank an afrika hat die zeitung
eine frage an herrn minister sparen wir
haben stellten jetzt eigentlich in
innsbruck wird das immer noch
aussuchen und partie auch bestellen
können
es geht weiterhin über die europäische
union wir haben ja auch für 2022 und 23
als eu weit über eine milliarde
dosen bestellt alleine von biontech um
eben auch entsprechend übrigens in die
verträge beinhalten auch klauseln in dem
moment wo es einen varianten angepassten
impfstoff geht also die impfstoffe
werden ja weiterentwickelt auf mögliche
varianten hin dass dann natürlich auch
dieser varianten angepasste impfstoff
dann derjenige ist den wir bekommen also
ja wir haben weiterhin gemeinsame
europäische verträge und über die auch
mehr als ausreichende menge auch für
2022 23 abgesichert
sodann wird ihre frage macht dann gehen
wir noch mal nach draußen bederkesa rtl
n tv nach der mpk am donnerstag waren
sich die ministerpräsidenten wohl einig
dass es im profisport dich wurde fußball
impfpflicht geben sollte stehen die
besonderen bereich bereich er zu diesem
thema
also mir ist über diese einigkeit nichts
bekannt insofern kann ich für ihn nicht
weder bestätigen noch dementieren
ich weiß nur eins das ist im grunde das
thema zwei gene also es geht ja nicht
darum ob der einzelne fußballer wenn er
zu hause ist geimpft es geht um die
frage ist dass einige richtig dass alle
im stadion geimpft sind nur die auf dem
platz möglicherweise nicht und ich finde
es vollkommen richtig dass wir auf
arbeit erscheint ob im restaurant oder
auf dem fußballplatz genauso geimpft
sein sollte wie die anderen
und vielleicht sogar gerade dem
profi-fußball noch eine besondere
vorbildfunktion und
dann haben wir noch eine frage von außen
ganze reihe mal gucken wir so
unterkriegen noch in der zeit thema
apotheken patrick hollstein von apotheke
adhoc sind corona impfungen im apotheken
nach der mpk endgültig vom tisch und ich
dann noch eine frage zu von patrick
hollstein der apotheken klagen über
massenhaft gefälschte zertifikate
wie lange macht das instrument noch sinn
und lassen sich die aussagen
rechtfertigen ist das konzept verfehlt
gibt es einen plan b um eine
kontrolle und fälschungssichere
zertifikat ermöglicht
also zuerst einmal die frage ob über die
erste schafft hinaus auch andere
gesundheitsberufe impfen können oder
nicht ist ist eine zu der man schnell
eine meinung haben kann was auch okay
ist die aber natürlich in der
rechtlichen umsetzung schon etwas
komplexer ist weil es um
haftungsrechtliche berufsrechtliche
fragen dabei geht im übrigen auch
umschulung und können
denn natürlich ich kenne das ja das
einmal sagen ja das ding in den oberarm
den pigs den kriegen doch auch andere
hin ja aber es macht schon auch sinn
dass zumindest mal ein arzt in der nähe
ist für den fall etwa dass es zu einem
entsprechenden allergischen schock kommt
und die gibt es sehr sehr selten aber
die gibt es
und da möchte man ja dann schon auch das
eben mein herz einer ärztin ein arzt
verfügbar ist und das ist ja
lebenspraktisch sabine arztpraxis oder
im impfzentrum dass nicht jede impfung
durch einen arzt durchgeführt wird
sondern auch andere
gesundheitsberufe
durchführen das auch immer ein arzt in
der nähe und verfügbar ist und in dem
moment wo sich das ändern würde die
brauchen sie ganz andere auch rechtliche
rahmen setzen soll wir sind gebeten
worden im mtk beschluss uns das noch
einmal anzuschauen und zu prüfen aber
und das auch gleich zu sagen ich sehe da
wenn jetzt nichts was kurzfristig geht
die frage in welchem umfang ist
tatsächlich notwendig ist muss man dann
auch nochmal miteinander besprechen
bei der frage ich habe ja möglich
gemacht ich würde mal sagen es war ich
dagegen enorm widerstand durchgesetzt
hat dass das modell projekte für
grippeimpfungen in apotheken gibt es ja
nicht so als wenn alle im deutschen
gesundheitswesen ist richtig gefunden
hätten das auch in apotheken grippe
impfung stattfinden können wir sehen bis
jetzt eine noch sehr zurückhaltende
teilnahme von apotheken auch an diesen
grippeimpfung und das ist vielleicht
dann auch noch mal ein hinweis darauf ob
und in welchem umfang er seine
unterschied macht oder machen kann aber
viel entscheidender ist die frage der
rechtlichen regelung die dann zu treffen
sind und die natürlich wenn sie gebeten
werden wir auch noch mal zu prüfen
sodann gibt es nochmal möglicherweise
eine klarstellung bedarf
weil es fragen gibt
die davon ausgehen dass moderner nicht
an kovacs geliefert werden können wegen
vertraglicher bestimmungen im vertrag
mit koo will vom tagesspiegel zum
beispiel fragt also ist das vermindert
werden also auch das ist das ist leider
immer alles sehr komplex
manchmal deswegen bin ich dankbar dass
ich das nochmal darstellen kann wichtig
ist sehr gefragt worden die verträge
sind mit der europäischen union gemacht
und deswegen muss es einen vertrag geben
auch der europäischen union mit dem
jeweiligen hersteller das sehen die
ursprungs verträge vor über abgabe an
dritte oder eine vereinbarung zumindest
das gilt nicht bei allen herstellern das
unterschiedliche art und weise ist das
in allen trägen drin was übrigens auch
was damit zu tun hat natürlich dass die
hersteller sagen wir verkaufen die
impfstoffe gerade nur an staatlicher
abnehmer und öffentliche institutionen
wollen schon irgendwie sicherstellen
können dass wir jetzt nicht zweit und
dritt märkte entstehen an anderer stelle
und es war unterschiedlich schnell
möglich das ist die wahrheit mit den
jeweiligen herstellern astrazeneca
johnson johnson biontech moderner dann
verträge vereinbarung zu schließen über
die abgabe an dritte
etwa eben über kovacs dafür gibt es
einen mustervertrag jeweils an denen
daneben die jeweiligen abgebenden länder
in denen die dann eintreten und der mit
moderner hat tatsächlich am längsten
gebraucht ist aber seit ende oktober da
und jetzt planen wir eben ein und ab
wann und in welchem umfang wir auch
moderner über kovacs an andere länder
geben können aber aufgrund unserer
bedarfe offenkundig die wir jetzt in der
eigenen kampagne haben wollen wir
natürlich auch die für so fördert mit
adressierten
gut dann gibt es fragen zur kombination
von
impfstoffen
zum einen folge vom park spiegel weist
darauf hin dass in den empfehlungen der
stiko und auf den webseiten des bmg es
heißt das für die auffrischung möglichst
der impfstoff der erstimpfung genutzt
werden solle ob das geändert werden
müsse
und
[Musik]
und dann nochmal an herrn sander die
frage habe ich es richtig verstanden
dass sie eine info mit drei impfstoffen
auch empfehlen würden also kombination
von drei impfstoffen also zuerst einmal
nur zu dem was von uns veröffentlicht
wurde das ist am ende ja auch das was
ich in der stiko empfehlung wieder
findet die ihm sagt wenn es geht der
gleiche aber genauso gut ist auch der
andere und das müssen wir eben klar
herausarbeiten
an der an der stelle und ich sage noch
einmal übrigens für viele wird auch die
möglichkeit bestehen
die gleichen oder nicht den gleichen zu
haben das bei dir ja immerhin auch noch
24 millionen dosen bei uns weghaben ich
finde aber die frage da kann können die
beiden viel mehr zu sagen aus
wissenschaftlicher sicht die frage dass
sozusagen eine hetero loock heißt der
kreuzung also der einen anderen stoff
benutzt das der sogar in manchen studien
zeigt dass die wirkung denn besser ist
ist doch eine die wir in unsere debatten
ruhig mit einbringen sollen
kann das gerne ergänzen der wunsch nach
homologe impfen entspricht dem der
zulassung wird von der jeweiligen
impfstoffherstellern beantragt das hat
sie ganz klar nicht studien
herausgestellt dass hetero logo impfung
da durchaus ihre vorteile haben
insbesondere fernlerner zur musterung
verwendet wir dass es der stand das
heißt das weiß ich auch nicht in die
entsprechenden stiko empfehlung erlaubt
dann darauf hin dass man zur hydrologen
booster impfung auch die erna impfstoffe
nicht nur verwenden kann sondern das ist
auch durchaus anders
da muss man ja sagen dass im grunde um
logistische erleichterung ja ist wenn
sie die möglichkeit haben
unterschiedliche impfstoffe zu
kombinieren sonst müssen sie ja immer
die terminierung von patienten die dann
reinkommen der hatte das zuerst und dann
dann dies und jenes jetzt kann ich aber
nur mit dem gleichen stoff wieder
boostern im grunde macht das ja
logistisch leichter und das muss ja
wirklich jetzt die prämisse sein dass
wir jetzt wirklich tempo machen die ist
der spanier hat zwar gesagt das nutzt
uns jetzt in den kommenden wochen nichts
aber der winter ist lang und im januar
und februar werden wir diesen booster
effekt mit sicherheit brauchen und jetzt
kommt es auf tempo an und die wie gesagt
die unterschiede sind marginal
wir hatten ja die ausnahme situation
dass wir jetzt leute haben die zunächst
mit astrazeneca und dann mit einem stoff
geimpft worden sind die können danach
wieder ein mmo im stoff bekommen wie
gesagt konform mit der stiko empfehlung
wäre das dann derselbe und wenn er nicht
da ist dann halt eben ein anderer ich
glaube es wichtige ist wirklich der
vorteil für den einzelnen impfling ist
ja tatsächlich möglichst schnell den
booster zu haben und keinen durchbruch
infektion zu bekommen und nicht welchen
welche welchen hersteller eines
impfstoffs man dann bekommt von daher
würde ich das sicher so empfehlen dass
man das frei kombinieren könnte
dann gibt es eine frage von gisela braun
vom gesundheitspolitischen
informationsdienst an professor jack
oder professor sander sie weist auf
einen aufsatz von peter de ski im
british medical journal wonach die
impfung oder booster impfung für
genesene mehr nebenwirkungen hervorrufen
kann eine studie an der auch andere die
sec beteiligt war zeige das gelesene
mindestens ein ja sehr gute bonität
aufweisen frage warum wird nicht aus dem
genesenen status getestet dort starb das
halbe jahr stadtstaates halbe jahr
vorzuschreiben schließlich argumentiert
man bei den impfungen und der booster
impfung auch mit der höhe des antikörper
spiegels dann müsste eine antikörper
bestimmung für den nachweis für genesen
wird doch möglich sein
also ganz klar ist es so dass wir davon
ausgehen dass der antikörper spiegeln
eine große rolle spielt bei der
entsprechenden schutzwirkung wir messen
habe die schutzwirkung auch die studien
und tun das umfeld das verbirgt sich in
tempore effektivität in dem verglichen
wird auch einander booster impfung
person infizieren sich danach die
gewusst hat wurden im vergleich zu denen
die gegen nur die grundimmunisierung
erreicht haben das ist eine klare
messung wir wissen noch nicht genau die
den antikörper spiegelt er wirklich
notwendig ist um zu einem schutz
zukommen und insofern wird sich die
diskussion dass man hier antikörper
level messen sollte es auch so dass
clarin was darauf bestehen dass genesene
durchaus einen sehr guten schutz haben
das feld tatsächlich unterschiedlich aus
je nachdem wie schwer die anfangs
infektion war aber nach den studien
lagen ist dieser sechs monate abstand
sicht und entspricht den stand der
aktion erkenntnissen
auch unterstützen diese impfung noch mal
nach sechs monaten erhöht den schutz
noch mal deutlich ähnlich weil der
booster impfung und man kann das eben
beobachten dass personen die vielleicht
auch mal eine sehr milde infektion haben
teilweise nicht kein sehr guten
impfschutz haben deswegen würde ich ganz
klar bei dieser empfehlung auch bleiben
nach sechs monaten diesen vom
wahrzunehmen wir wollen den optimalen
schutz auch wieder mit hinblick auf das
virus nicht weiter zu geben also
deswegen würde ich das ein genießen in
dem film
also den fehler geht weil das auto mal
gefragt wird wie lange dauert der
impfschutz wie lange hält den schutz vor
einer neuen infektionen bei genesen das
bezog sie jetzt gerade auf die nächsten
habe ich das bei teilen der standard
sechs monaten ist die frage damit auch
beantworten dann gehen wir noch mal in
den saal essen trinken sie hat noch mal
zweite frage
erspart ich bitte noch eine präzisierung
der zahlen bei den spenden die wahren
freunden im bereich von ich glaub 70
millionen dosen die sie genannt haben
vor zehn tagen am 12 november sagte die
bundesregierung deutschland werde bis
zum jahresende noch 100 millionen dosen
spenden davon die hälfte im stoffe und
zum selben stichtag waren 19 millionen
davon geliefert bleiben sie bei der
zusage dass bis zum jahresende weitere
80 millionen geliefert werden und wie
viele davon wurden zwischen dem zwölften
und heute geliefert was ist also noch
offen bleibt es dabei dass die hälfte
davon mr dem chef sein will dann füge
ich die frage noch nicht rein von außen
von sebastian fischer vom spiegel ob die
erwarteten lieferungen auch genügen um
den bedarf an impfungen für fünf- bis
zwölfjährige zu decken denn die
empfehlung kommt
also zu den fünf bis zwölfjährigen hatte
ich ja gerade schon ausgeführt mache ich
aber gerne noch mal weil das wichtig ist
beschäftigt fehler natürlich auch
insbesondere die eltern
für die fünf bis zwölf oder fünf bis
elfjährigen genau genommen wird eben ein
anderer eine andere dosierung andere
fläschchen andere produktionen sozusagen
dann ausgeliefert werden in der zweiten
dezemberhälfte in einer ersten lieferung
an deutschland und zur selben zeit an
alle anderen eu-länder aber für
deutschland 2,4 millionen dosen wir
haben etwa
doppelt so viel los - kinder in dem
alter in deutschland das heißt also ich
gehe davon aus dass den erst bedarf die
erste nachfrage die wir nach dem kinder
impfstoff dann haben werden nach der
auslieferung wir auch werden damit
decken können und schon im januar
februar folgen weitere lieferung des
kinder impfstoffs wir haben bei den 12
bis 17 jährigen stand heute morgen 50
prozent erst impfquote jetzt erreicht
nach vielen vielen wochen wo der
impfstoff bereits verfügbar ist also 2,4
millionen dosen ist etwa 50 prozent des
überhaupt denkbaren bedarf es wenn sich
jeder in dem alter impfen lassen würde
ich bin sehr sicher dass wir damit die
anfangs nachfrage gut werden decken
können was die frage kovacs angeht ist
dieses kovacs ist und das auch noch
einmal zu erläutern
ein sehr komplexes ging natürlich weil
am ende die lieferung von vielen staaten
und die lieferung an viele staaten jeder
koordiniert werden muss und wenn wir
sagen wir können nicht mal eben sagen
wir geben morgen aber noch einmal drei
millionen dosen rüber das hat ganz
andere vorlaufzeiten das heißt dass das
manchmal schwer sozusagen
nachvollziehbar ist welche komplexitäten
und jungs zeiten da drin sind wenn ich
jetzt lese ihr habt dabei im november
noch bei montech abgegeben an kovacs
mussten august entscheiden also das ist
ja das sind ja vorlaufzeiten die eben
nicht mal eben wir können jetzt jede
woche wechseln sind deswegen ist das ist
das manchmal etwas länger als geplant
und das zweite ist wir machen eine
zusage dass wir verbindlich abgeben aber
dann muss es auch erstmal länder geben
die aufnehmen können denn ob sie es
glauben oder nicht es gibt auch
situationen wo in ländern die adressat
einer impfstoff spende sind die sagen
wir können jetzt kurzfristig gar nicht
so viel in unser system aufnehmen wir
gar nicht die ärzte die struktur vor ort
haben auch in einigen ländern etwa in
afrika in anderen ländern dass wir
überhaupt schnell genug alles umsetzen
können deswegen ist dieses austarieren
wann was genau passiert eben ein
komplexer vorgang der bei kovacs
passiert tatsächlich
ausgeliefert sind tatsächlich die 20
millionen dosen knapp 20 millionen dosen
fest zugesagt auch für den weiteren
verlauf des jahres sind die 68 millionen
dosen die ich gerade genannt habe auch
in der aufteilung wie ich sie gerade
genannt habe was wir darüber hinaus noch
bis ende des jahres verbindlich zusagen
oder gar schon in die auslieferung
bekommen werden wir jetzt eben ich habe
die würziger sagen kannst du schon
öffentlich gesagt die dezember biontech
lieferung an kovacs haben wir gestoppt
weil wir offenkundig bedarf in
deutschland haben das löst jetzt
natürlich in anderen ländern
dann auch erstmal nicht nur begeisterung
aus aber ich finde meine these war immer
die habe ich auch immer in genf bei der
wm vertreten nur wenn die dinge zu hause
in ordnung sind ist eine akzeptanz dafür
da auch impfstoff in die welt zu gehen
deswegen machen wir gerade beides
impfstoffe zu hause zu haben sozusagen
für die impfung in deutschland und in
die welt zu geben wir werden die 100
millionen
früh also rund um den jahreswechsel
vielleicht wird es auch ein bisschen
später aber werden sie natürlich
erfüllen und auch darüber hinaus noch
gehen können in den folgemonaten aber es
wird sich jetzt möglicherweise wegen des
gestiegenen bedarf ist durch die booster
impfung bei über 18 jährigen etwas
verzögern zu setzen
sie sagten eben fest zugesagt seien 68
millionen das bedeutet die 68 zusätzlich
zu den bereits ausgeliefert und 20
inklusive es schon wenn sie sagen
insgesamt 68 bis jahresende zugesagt das
ist eine andere zahl als die bisher
gehörten 100 millionen am vor zehn tagen
erklärte die bundesregierung wir werden
auf jeden fall in diesem jahr bis zum
jahresende 100 millionen dosen sie
fanden jetzt hat sagen sie 68 sind
zugesagt das ist eine differenz von 32
millionen das stimmt
zuerst einmal das eine ist eine
politische zusage
die 100 millionen das andere ist die
vertragliche umsetzung ihre frage war ja
in der vorherigen frage wie viel ist
konkret schon in der umsetzung der zwei
verschiedene dinge politische zusage
muss dann erfüllt werden durch
entsprechende vertragliche vereinbarung
vertraglich vereinbart sind bis hierhin
jetzt mit dem november
68 millionen es werden im zweifel auch
noch mehr werden können bis ende des
jahres wie viel mehr werde ich jetzt im
lichte des bedarfes für die deutsche
kampagne
daneben mit den kolleginnen und kollegen
entscheiden das entscheidet und es auch
nicht das bundesministerium für
gesundheit sondern jede einzelne kovacs
spende wird natürlich innerhalb der
bundesregierung mit dem auswärtigen amt
mit dem bmz mit dem finanzministerium
entsprechend abgestimmt also die 100
millionen
vor zehn tagen gelten heute nicht das
kann man abschließend ob sie jetzt genau
sozusagen auf 100 millionen erreicht
werden oder nicht können wir heute
abschließend noch nicht sagen und sein
ziel ist aber weiterhin so viel wie es
geht oder so nah wie es geht an diese
100 millionen zu kommen aber sie haben
ja auch mitbekommen hessen vielleicht
das in den letzten 4 6 wochen sich die
diskussion etwas weiterentwickelt hat
so jetzt habe ich noch fragen im saal
rinke der kollege hier vorne
linke fängt an und ich schon mal dazu
sagen es gibt noch eine ganze reihe
fragen von außen werden nicht alle dran
kommen können
ich hätte ganz gern nach einem anderen
aspekt gefragt der sich jetzt da ist und
zwar zu den schnelltest sie jetzt auch
mass nachfolger eingesetzt werden sollen
das hat gestern einen bericht gegeben
über die mangelnde qualität dieser
schnelltests die aber natürlich ein
pfeiler der ganzen pandemie bekämpfung
ist und jetzt ja auch wieder wichtiger
werden soll vielleicht können sie uns
dann nochmal der einschätzung geben
warum sind tests auf dem markt wo die
nutzer nicht erkennen können ob die
einfach effektiv sind oder nicht
ich fange mal gerne an
auf geheiß und bitte des
gesundheitsministers haben wir von
seinem paul ehrlich institut unserer
expertise im testen in der performance
prüfung von antigen schnelltest
eingesetzt wir machen das kontinuierlich
weiter sie können auf unserer webpage
lesen welche tests einen gewissen
standard haben der standard besteht
darin dass bei mittleren und hohen virus
level über 75 bis 80 prozent der proben
erkannt werden das panel stammt vom rk
ii die test bei uns diese positivliste
ist am paul-ehrlich-institut zu finden
und sie ist genauso zugegen beim
zuständigen bundesinstitut für
arzneimittel
die zehn produkte beim fahren das heißt
ja von vornherein dafür gesorgt dass die
tests an ständig geprüft wurden und nach
den entsprechenden standards
evaluiert wurden und dass auch allgemein
bekannt wurde
hieß es von den test nicht geschaffen
haben sind auch von der pva müsste die
tiefs gestrichen okay das heißt sie sind
auch nicht im handel nur um das zu
verstehen doch das eine ist eine cd also
es ist wie immer alles komplex ist eine
ist die ce zertifizierung für den zugang
zum europäischen markt die ce
zertifizierung ist keine die deutschland
macht sondern sind sogenannte benannte
stellen tüv oder andere aber auch in
allen anderen 26 mitgliedstaaten das
sind der medizinprodukte die das machen
und mit der ce zertifizierung ist der
marktzugang da dann sind wir zu der
erkenntnis gekommen dass reicht nicht
weil ce zertifizierung nicht per se
ausreichten qualität jedenfalls nach
unseren standards bedeutet also haben
wir zusätzlich eingezogen eine prüf
linie dankenswerterweise in guter
zusammenarbeit von paul ehrlich institut
die ich hatte mir selbst mal angeguckt
vor der pandemie sogar auch andere tests
hiv-test und anderes überprüfen auf ihre
qualität und dem bv für die
medizinprodukte zulassung zuständig und
wir haben eben gesagt auch im rahmen
unserer test verordnung also da wo wir
auch sozusagen öffentlich bezahlen tests
dann nur die wo auch bei und b fahren
den stempel drauf gemacht haben bzw
zeitnah drauf machen und das hat dazu
geführt die überprüfung dass einige von
dieser liste wieder runtergekommen sind
das heißt sie werden nicht mehr
erstattet im rahmen der test verordnung
zum beispiel und im rahmen der
kostenlosen bürger tests sie sind aber
weiterhin im markt weil sie die
europaweite er
zertifizierung und medizinprodukte zu
lassen haben die dass die qualität der
tests sehr sehr unterschiedlich ist
übrigens ein thema das uns jetzt auch
schon seit zwölf bis 18 monaten
begleitet wo es ja auch bei dem bei der
frage der kosten ich meine einerseits
sagen alle die bürger tests sollen nicht
so viel kosten einerseits gibt es auch
bei den tests zumindest nicht selten
auch eine korrelation zwischen preis und
qualität und das sind eben die
diskussionen die wir beständig ja seit
über 12 18 monaten führen und sind
wichtige hinweis nicht jeder schnelltest
ist gleich gut das ist so
dann haben wir ihre frage noch die
kollegin von der berliner zeitung hat
auch noch eine frage offen ist erledigt
sonst im saal nichts mehr schauen wir
dass wir die noch dann klicke bitte
blick auf die nachlassende wirkung der
impfstoffe und die notwendigkeit der
booster ist gibt es politische
überlegungen die das zertifikat von
einem jahr auf wer ticks verkürzen oder
vielleicht auch an die professorin
inwiefern das medizinisch sinnvoll ist
also politische planung und medizinische
in öffentlichkeit davon also zur frage
der politisch pandemischen planung so zu
sagen was er immer ein zusammenspiel von
politisch und fachlichen erwägungen ist
sind wir im gespräch und im austausch
mit unseren europäischen partnern wir
möchten nämlich gerne ein europäisch
einheitliches vorgehen es ist jetzt
schon so dass 27 mitgliedstaaten zum
teil sehr unterschiedliche
vorgehensweisen haben in der frage für
wie lange dann eine entsprechende
impfung sozusagen als folge impft im
sinne der rechtslage der jeweiligen des
landes gilt ich fänd's gut macht auch
sinn für reisen innerhalb der eu wenn
wir das einheitlich miteinander
vereinbaren würden und ja dazu gehört
auch die debatte ob man sozusagen die
die die rechtliche wirkung zweifach
geimpft heißt voll geschützt im sinne
oder folge impfte im sinne des rechtes
etwa für 2g
dass wir da über eine verkürzung in der
eu diskutieren das ist so aber ich finde
es ihm wichtig dass das gemeinsam
passiert und vor allem passiert in einem
zusammenhang wo auch alle bürgerinnen
und bürger die chance gehabt haben ihre
dann nach dem zeitraum anstehende dritte
impfung zu haben aber die diskussion
gibt es ja
so dann würde ich zum schluss noch von
den übrigen fragen von außen noch 2
zusammenbinden unterschiedlichen
zielrichtungen
minister sprachen zum einen von angela
mißlbeck hat der nachrichtendienst die
frage wie stehen sie zur forderung nach
einem bonus für medizinische
fachangestellte in den arztpraxen wegen
der zusätzlichen belastungen analog zum
pflegekräfte boden aus in krankenhäusern
und dann themen stechen von zeit online
weist darauf hin zu berichten es sei in
hamburg
ins zentrum zu chaotischen szenen mit
polizeieinsatz gekommen weil dort eben
viele weg geschickt worden sein
weil das mobile im feierabend machen
wollte und in berlin habe man ihm fehle
zurückgeschickt weil ihnen wenige tage
bis zur 5 monatsfrist feten ist dieses
vorgehen aus ihrer sicht
also zuerst einmal zu der frage des der
hat der mögliche bonuszahlungen
verstehe ich die diskussion sehr gut ich
weiß auch aus verschiedenen gesprächen
und schalten auch mit den verbänden der
medizinischen fachangestellten
was da los war und ist seit beginn der
pandemie aber natürlich auch immer zu
bestimmten phasen der impfkampagne in
den arztpraxen an den telefonen in den e
mail accounts am tresen dass die beiden
themen ändern sich insofern als dass die
frage auf wie gehen wir miteinander oben
in der zeit von stress und manchmal auch
ungeduld natürlich an jedem arzt tresen
eine rolle spielt und man sich viel
anhören muss was inakzeptabel ist manch
einer sogar etwas übergriffig dabei wird
nicht nur verbal und ich ist erst mal
finde ich das was sie auch berichtet
haben aus hamburg aus berlin was wir
auch aus anderen stellen berichtet
bekommen es gibt es ja von zwei seiten
es gibt zum einen diejenigen die im
skeptisch oder gegner sind die zum teil
die das impfen personal angreifen und
dann gibt es diejenigen die ungeduldig
sind aus nachvollziehbaren gründen
ungeduldig sind aber am ende ist
manchmal dann an denen auslassen die am
wenigsten dafür können wenn jetzt eben
kein impfstoff aktuell zum beispiel vor
ort verfügbar ist und deswegen kenne ich
immer nur wieder um auch geduld
miteinander
und bitten ich habe mal gesagt wenn sie
wenn sie sauber sein wollen dann seien
sie sauer auf mich aber nicht auf
diejenigen die vor ort unter nicht
leichten bedingungen das alles immer
auch umsetzen müssen und das gilt auch
für diese phase weiterhin deswegen kann
ich auch gut verstehen dass da eben eine
finanzielle anerkennung im sinne eines
bonus auch angezeigt ist wir haben jetzt
die vergütung für die impfung noch mal
erhöht um acht euro und am wochenende um
nochmals acht euro auf 36 euro
vielleicht ist es ja auch möglich einen
teil dieser erhöhung geben für die
vergütung der medizinischen
fachangestellten
einzusetzen
wenn es da an haben wir sind am ende
alle diejenigen die nicht daran gekommen
sind muss ich um verständnis bitten die
nächste pressekonferenz beginnt gleich
mit dem sein vater wieder
still